Intervall in ragunjeßnitz einer
Kleinstadt in Sachsen-Anhalt die übrigen
Parteien hatten versucht den jeweiligen
afd-kandidatin zu verhindern geklappt
hat das nicht und was heißt das jetzt
Populisten im Aufwind alles nur Protest
das ist mein Thema heute bei Unter den
Linden herzlich willkommen dazu und das
sind meine Gäste Jan Redmann Landes- und
Fraktionsvorsitzender der CDU
Brandenburg und der Soziologe Harald
Welzer ihnen beiden herzlich willkommen
hier im Studio
was machen wir jetzt mit den beiden
Wahlen die ich in der Anmoderation
genannt habe normalerweise fragen wir
uns ja schon nach Landtagswahlen welche
Aussagekraft so ein Ergebnis für die
Bundespolitik hat jetzt sprechen wir von
einer Landratswahl mit 12.000
Wahlberechtigten unter einer
Bürgermeisterwahlen mit ca 8000
Wahlberechtigten ist die Aufregung
berechtigt oder hin wird das Ganze zu
hoch
naja das kommt auf die Perspektive an
wenn man das ganze um die gegenwärtigen
Umfragen Deutschland trennt und so
weiter ergänzt sehen wir ja dass es dort
eine Partei gibt die sozusagen
kontinuierliche
Zustimmungswerte die wachsen bekommt und
was ich interessant finde eigentlich
ohne eigenes zu tun aber wir haben ja
gegenwärtig eine gesellschaftspolitische
Situation wo eben genau diese AFD
ständig sozusagen höhere
Zustimmungswerte bekommt und jetzt auch
solche Wahlen gewinnt ohne jetzt
irgendwo sichtbar wäre was hätte sich
bei denen außer dass sie noch extremer
geworden sind verändert und so und
insofern ist glaube ich worüber man
sprechen sollte sozusagen die gesamte
Stimmung unter den Wählerinnen und
Wählern etwas worauf man gucken muss das
passt vielleicht Herr Redmann was sagt
das aus ihrer Sicht über den Zustand
unserer Gesellschaft aus wenn eine
randpartei jedenfalls bundespolitisch
betrachtet wenn auch nur in einem
Landkreis bzw jetzt in einer kleinen
Stadt gegen das gesamte westliche
Politik politische Spektrum gewinnen
kann
naja ich fühle mich ein kleines bisschen
erinnert an die 90er Jahre als die CDU
glaubte mit einer roten Socken Kampagne
die Linkspartei klein zu machen und
genau das Gegenteil davon ist
eingetreten die Linkspartei ist immer
größer geworden hat am Ende Brandenburg
sogar mal bei einer Landtagswahl 28 %
geholt und was wir jetzt sehen ist dass
dieses Konzept Schulterschluss gegen die
AFD alle Parteien Haken sich unter dass
das gar nicht funktioniert denn die AFD
profitiert davon eigentlich da gibt es
dann da gibt es Effekte der
Polarisierung die sie eigentlich groß
machen ich habe das auch 2019 in
Brandenburg im Landtagswahlkampf erlebt
da stand die AFD vorher vor den Wahlen
so bei 17 18 Prozent dann setzte die
Polarisierung alle gegen die AFD ein und
sie ging hoch auf 23,5 und diese Effekte
sehen wir glaube ich auch an anderen
Orten und ich wünsche mir dass es uns
gelingt das ist den Parteien die mit
beiden Beinen auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes gelingt wieder die
spannenden politischen Debatten unter
sich auszumachen da muss die Kontroverse
sein und dann glaube ich wird es auch
weniger interessant die AFD zu wählen
wenn die Wähler sehen sie haben auch
eine echte Auswahl zwischen den
demokratischen Parteien wenn wir uns
unterhalten sind wir so langweilig wie
eine märkische Kiefern Monokultur sie
haben jetzt das äh Beispiele aus den
90ern genannt also würden sie jetzt in
der direkte Parallele zu beispielsweise
Sonneberg ziehen wollen da wurde ja auch
der CDU-Kandidat von allen übrigen
Parteien unterstützen das hat schade
dass ihre naja vielleicht nicht von
allen aber ich glaube man muss auch
immer also man muss immer genau gucken
warum wird ein Kandidat unterstützt wenn
ein Kandidat nur unterstützt wird um die
AFD zu verhindern erzeugt dass diesen
polarisierungseffekt wenn ein Kandidat
unterstützt wird weil die anderen
Parteien aus inhaltlichen Gründen
überzeugt sind dass der ein guter
Landrat wäre dann schadet das sicherlich
nicht konkret auf Sonneberg bezogen ich
glaube nicht dass dem CDU-Kandidaten die
Unterstützung und die Wahlempfehlung der
Linkspartei besonders genutzt hat sehen
Sie das auch besser also dieses Konzept
aller gegen eine gegen einen Bescheid
hat naja psychologisch würde man sagen
das erzeugt Reaktanz weil es einfach so
ist es dann Leute die da ähm mit dieser
wahlaufgabe fast sind sagen ich soll
jetzt das wählen und das ist schlecht ja
das will eigentlich niemand und das ist
ja auch nicht dieses Wesen einer
demokratisches auch ganz schön
empfindlich wenn er dieses Gefühl
bekommt
sogar sein aber ich glaube das ist
kontraproduktiv sowas zu machen
und es ist ja auch schwer sich zu
überlegen wir reden ja jetzt über eine
Situation die sozusagen eine Geschichte
von zehn Jahren Erfolg dieser Partei hat
und das ist ja glaube ich etwas was
schwierig zu diskutieren ist weil das ja
bedeutet das gewissermaßen diese
Rhetorik der Brandmauer und der
Abgrenzung und mit denen kann man nicht
und das wird nicht ja zumindestens
keinen Erfolg in den Wahlen hat ja und
insofern muss man vielleicht die Optik
etwas erweitern nämlich wie geht man mit
denen um unter dieser Voraussetzung dass
das bislang noch nichts genützt hat
zweitens wie geht man eigentlich mit
denen um wenn man vergleichbare Prozesse
in den USA in Italien in Österreich und
so weiter sich anguckt das heißt wir
haben es ja dieser Mythos das ist etwas
vorübergehen das was man durch ausgrenzt
und bekämpfen kann das ist
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich ein Mythos
und damit wird man sie nicht loswerden
die Statik dieser Brandmauer wollen wir
uns gleich auch noch mal genauer
anschauen ich würde aber an diesem und
gerne noch mal nachhaken wollen also ist
dieses Konzept alle gegen einen
gescheitert oder ist das jetzt eine
Momentaufnahme ich glaube das ist
gescheitert ich glaube das hat auch
keine Zukunft weil am Ende würde es ja
sogar Demokratie theoretisch eine Frage
aufwerfen also das ist das ist ja nicht
durchhaltbar und das wird vor allen
Dingen auch nicht durch haltbar sein für
den vielleicht unwahrscheinlichen Fall
dass dann solche Leute auf der
kommunalpolitischen Ebene oder sowas
eine erfolgreiche Politik machen das ist
ja alles gar nicht auszuschließen und
was macht man denn dann kann man doch
nicht aus einem Prinzip heraus die
kommenden 30 Jahren sein wir machen dann
jedes Mal wenn so eine Wahl gibt ähm die
große gemeinsame Gruppe gegen die das
Wissen nicht funktionieren psychologisch
nicht und Demokratie theoretisch nicht
im Titel der Sendung Fragen danach ob
das Wählen einer Partei die von vielen
ja als populistisch bezeichnet wird nur
Protest ist das
nur sicherlich nicht die Ursachen dafür
sind vielfältig aber mehrheitlich ist
die Wahl der AFD eine Protestwahl das
ergeben ja auch nach wahlbefragung
vieler Orten das hat sich immer mal
wieder verändert aber gegenwärtig zum
Beispiel ist es wieder stärker eine
Protest weil als es noch bei der
Bundestagswahl 2017 der Fall war ist die
meisten afd-wähler wollen eigentlich den
etablierten Parteien damit ein Signal
geben und ihnen zeigen sie fühlen sich
zu wenig einbezogen sie fühlen sich zu
wenig verstanden abgeholt eure Politik
die ihr da macht geht an uns vorbei es
ist also eigentlich auch ein Zeichen der
kulturellen Entfremdung würden Sie dem
zustimmen das ist ja eigentlich relativ
einfach immer von einer Protest Wahl zu
sprechen oder sagt das war auch etwas
über diejenigen aus die sehr gerne
schnell diesen Begriff der Protest war
bemühen ja es ist ein bisschen einfach
diesen Begriff heranzuziehen erstens
deswegen weil es natürlich mittlerweile
eine stabile parteipolitische
Abteilung gibt die uns nicht mehr
verlässt bei einer reinen Protestpartei
wie bei den Piraten oder sowas wäre das
es gibt es mal eine Legislaturperiode
dann sind die wieder weg oder im
rechtspopulistischen Spektrum hat es ist
auch vorher gegeben die Republikaner und
so etwas dann sind die wieder weg hier
ist es nicht der Fall dann ist es auch
nicht ist das eine Unterschätzung wenn
man sagt das ist eine Protestpartei weil
es könnte ja so sein das ist ein
stabiles Wählerinnen und Wählerpotential
gibt das tatsächlich an diesem rechten
Rand aus Gründen die sich selber
vertreten so eine Partei wählt weil sie
die Inhalte gut finden dazu kann man
sagen es gibt ja seit sehr vielen Jahren
die Studien zur gruppenbezogene
Menschenfeindlichkeit die kollegenheit
Meier und zwicklers Bielefeld die das
seit vielen Jahren machen und wir wissen
vorher auch aus ähnlichen Forschung wir
haben auch in der Bundesrepublik so
einen Anteil von 20% in der Bevölkerung
Menschen die er Vorurteils beladen sind
Erich haben eher antisemitisch sind so
und diese 20 Prozent haben eine Heimat
in dieser Partei gefunden und da kommen
an die finden Sie in anderen Parteien
offensichtlich für sich nicht mehr und
insofern stabilisieren sich da diese
Wählerpotenzial und dann kommen und top
da muss man dann darüber diskutieren
länderspezifische
Faktoren dazu also Ostdeutschland hat
dann größeres Potenzial als
Westdeutschland und und und da muss man
vielleicht in die Geschichte gucken
woran es liegt aber jedenfalls läuft
alles auf den Befund zu dass es kein
vorübergehendes Phänomen ist und das
wird natürlich starke Fragen auf für die
auf die etablierten Parteien wie wollt
ihr denn damit umgehen erhält man er
Wälzer hat am Anfang seiner Ausführung
gesagt man unterschätzt möglicherweise
wenn man diesen Begriff der
Protestpartei nutzt diejenigen die
gewählt werden unterschätzen Sie
möglicherweise die AFD ja ich habe ja
gesagt dass es nicht alle Wähler sind
die aus Protest fehlen sondern es gibt
durchaus umfragen sagen etwa ein Drittel
die durchaus aus inhaltlicher
Überzeugung die AFD wählen und natürlich
gibt es in Ost- wie Westdeutschland auch
Menschen die rechtsextreme Ansichten
vertreten und die bei der AFD in zu
Hause gefunden haben wir hatten vorher
auch schon zwei Legislaturperioden lang
die die edvu im brandenburgischen
Landtag die waren vorher dort sind dann
zur AFD rübergegangen und dann kommt
protestfehler noch oben drauf die bei
anderen Wahlen möglicherweise die
Linkspartei gewählt haben und dann zur
AFD rüber sind das alles ähm ist sicher
war ich wäre mich aber dagegen dass als
so ein ostdeutsches Phänomen
darzustellen also es gibt auch
Antisemitismus in Westdeutschland es
gibt Rechtsextremismus in
Westdeutschland es gibt auch autoritäre
Ansicht in Westdeutschland und die
Situation in Ostdeutschland ist sehr
unterschiedlich auch in verschiedenen
Regionen aus Deutschlands jetzt da
einfach die alte die Mauer wieder
aufzubauen und zu sagen man kann es ganz
einfach mit Osten Westdeutschland
erklären stimmt nicht ähm auch die
jüngsten Studien aus Leipzig haben große
Unterschiede ergeben zwischen Thüringen
und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Beispiel
beispielsweise in Brandenburg ist
Antisemitismus geringer ausgeprägt als
im Schnitt in Westdeutschland
beispielsweise also da sieht man auch
ziemlich große Unterschiede und da hilft
es glaube ich nicht jetzt so in so eine
so eine bevölkerungsgruppenbeschimpfung
reinzugehen und auch keine
Bevölkerungsgruppen Beschimpfung
differenzieren
unterschiedliche Wahlergebnisse sie
haben tatsächlich jetzt die Problematik
bei der nächsten Landtagswahlen dass die
AFD möglicherweise sehr hohe
Stimmenanteile bekommt und zwar höherer
als beispielsweise in
Nordrhein-Westfalen oder in
Niedersachsen oder so das ist erstmal
ein Sachverhalte keine Beschimpfung und
dann müsste man sich gerade als
Politiker darüber Gedanken machen woran
liegt das denn dann können wir darüber
diskutieren woran es liegen könnte da
gibt sich ja keine Marmor gemeinsame
Wahrheit darüber aber es gibt
unterschiedliche Faktoren ein Faktor aus
meiner Sicht ist sicherlich der dass man
sehr sehr lange in bestimmten
ostdeutschen
tun viel zu Toleranz mit rechtsextremen
und Nazis umgegangen ist das ist zum
Beispiel ein Faktor ein anderer Faktor
ist muss man die Geschichte gucken eine
viel längere diktaturerfahrung die
einfach auch eine bestimmte Form von
mentaler Prägung nach sich zieht und der
dritte Faktor ist es möglicherweise
diejenigen wir haben ja mal eine
Generation direkt nach der Wende gehabt
die Baseballschläger Jahre sozusagen das
sind ja jetzt Leute im mittleren
Lebensalter die Kinder haben und
möglicherweise bestimmte Einstellungen
weitergegeben haben also es hilft ja
überhaupt nicht weiter und das dann als
Beschimpfung zu bezeichnen sondern man
muss ja gucken was sind denn die
Motivlagen was sind die Mentalitäten von
bestimmten Wählergruppen dafür dass sie
sich in diese Richtung entscheiden also
ich möchte Ihnen zwei Punkten
widersprechen bzw einmal widersprechen
und einmal ergänzen der eine Punkt ist
dass man in Ostdeutschland nicht
konsequent gegen Rechtsextremismus
vorgegangen ist ich habe in den 90er
Jahren Abitur gemacht in Wittstock ganz
im Norden von Brandenburg
Rostock war eine Hochburg des
Rechtsextremismus in Brandenburg selber
die Behörden haben damals für eine
Kleinstadt 10.000 Einwohner 60
gewaltbereite Neonazis auflisten können
namentlich auflisten können dem es
begegnet worden durch Sondereinheiten
der Polizei natürlich auch mit sehr viel
Sozialarbeit aber vor allen Dingen
Sondereinheiten der Polizei die den
Nazis richtig auf dem Senkel standen da
konnte keine garagenparty mehr mit
illegaler Musik gefeiert werden am
Wochenende ohne das nicht gleich zwei
Einsatzwagen der Polizei vor Ort stand
ist einfach auch deutlich gemacht haben
der Staat steht dagegen ist wurde uncool
rechtsextreme zu meinen zu seiner mein
Gymnasium damals auf dem Schulhof war
Rechtsextremismus die vorherrschende
Jugendkultur und all die
ausdifferenzierten Jugendkulturen im
linken Bereich gab es gar nicht es gab
normale und es gab rechtsextreme und das
war die einzige Jugendkultur und das hat
sich verändert das gibt's nicht mehr
auch Ostdeutschland ist viel bunter
geworden durch all diese Maßnahmen auch
weil man konsequenter gegen vorgegangen
ist wenn Sie heute auf den Schulhof
desselben Gymnasiums gehen werden Sie
ganz andere Strömung finden der rechtsex
ist natürlich auch nicht mehr so
äußerlich erkennbar mit
Baseballschlägern mit irgendwelchen
Bomberjacken und mit Glatzen und so
weiter es mag auch was anderes ein und
jetzt die ganze Zeit wenn ich noch kurz
darf wenn sie sich die wenn sie sich
bestimmte Ansichten anschauen und und
Regionen miteinander vergleichen dann
werden sie auf Gemeinsamkeiten stoßen
immer dort wo die Strukturschwäche
besonders groß ist und wir haben normal
in Ostdeutschland recht flächendecken
strukturschwache Regionen noch mal
Wittstock ist die sechs größte Stadt
Deutschlands flächenmäßig größer als
Köln flächenmäßig ja eine Stadt mit 18
Ortsteilen sehr sehr dünn besiedelt von
meinem abituria Jahrgang sind 80%
weggegangen und auch nur ein kleiner
Teil wiedergekommen als wir vor zwei als
wir von ein paar Jahren 20 Jahre Abi
Treffen hatten waren 70% des Jahrgangs
wieder da die sind für dieses Abitur
treffen zurückgekommen haben sich
gefreut und als ich die da alle auf dem
Marktplatz stehen haben mit ihrem das
Weißwein in der Hand dachte ich so ja
ihr seid die die fehlen
ihr seid die die uns fehlen die
fehlenden den Familien die fehlen in den
Betrieben die fehlen auch in der
Gesellschaft und das ist ein und das ist
ein Punkt den haben wir in allen
strukturschwachen Regionen des junge
Leute ambitionierte Leute weggehen und
das dann am Ende auch die Gesellschaft
am sich dadurch natürlich in gewisser
Weise verändert das ist kein Spezialist
die das tatsächlich stützen das der
Osten teilweise sehr vergleichbar ist
mit Industrie Regionen im Westen
wird gerne ein Punkt noch mal aufgreifen
natürlich könnte man jetzt sagen wenn
man sich das wiederum auch einfach
machen will dass die Menschen im Osten
möglicherweise die Demokratie nicht
verstanden haben aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen oder nicht so dran gewöhnt sind
aber muss man nicht auch andersrum viel
stärker danach fragen warum muss der der
demokratische Politik Betrieb im Osten
nicht geschafft hat den Menschen als
glaubwürdig zu erscheinen er das sind
große Fragen also dass das der lässt
sich ja jetzt sozusagen nicht mit einem
Satz drauf antworten das sind ja
gemengeladen natürlich hat es viel zu
tun damit mit all diesen Themen die wir
schon sehr oft diskutiert haben die
jetzt auch in diesem neuen Bestsellern
mit immer thematisiert werden sozusagen
das Posten
Lehrstühle und sonst was von den Westen
und so weiter dass es kein paritätischer
Vorgang gewesen ist dieses was nach der
Wiedervereinigung und so weiter passiert
ist das Lebensleistungen entwertet
wurden und und und und übrigens gibt mir
alles das überhaupt noch keinen Grund
dafür weshalb man dann AFD wählen sollte
ja also selbst wenn man
deklassierungserfahrungen der
täuschungserfahrung hat die haben ja
nichts anzubieten um das zu kompensieren
insofern finde ich auch das immer
kurzschlüssig aber er redet man hat das
eben ja selber auch ausgeführt das
Weggehen von Leuten bedeutet ja auch es
bleiben nur bestimmte da ja die die
vielleicht die modernisierungser sind
wir haben ja auch ein Männlichkeit
weiblichkeitsproblem das sind ja
unmittelbar nach der Wende viel mehr
Frauen weggegangen und haben anderswo
Karriere gemacht und dann sind irgendwie
Männer dort geblieben dann gibt es ein
größere Ressentiment weil so ein
wählerpool für extreme Orientierung
insbesondere rechts sind ja auch junge
Männer und und und das heißt es ist ein
ganzes Bündel von Faktoren und ich will
ja auch gar nicht in Abrede stellen dass
wir ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem
damit haben aber es nützt ja nichts zu
sagen das ist überall gleich weil das
ist nicht überall gleich und um
politische Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen
muss man auch diese Differenzen zu
erkennen ist man haben Sie denn da eine
Erklärung drauf was ja fakt ist in der
Tat vor der AFD gab es die Linkspartei
die viele Stimmen bei den Wahlen in
Ostdeutschland auf sich Verein konnte
also jetzt ist es die AFD die sozusagen
zu dieser neuen Volkspartei des Ostens
aufstrebt warum gibt es überhaupt diesen
Platz im Osten warum schaffen es nicht
äh die Parteien der Mitte die Wähler an
sich zu bindend
das das Potenzial für diese Art von
Protestwahl ist ja auch in den letzten
30 Jahren immer sehr unterschiedlich
groß gewesen also wir hatten auch eine
AFD ist ja seit 2014 und Brandenburger
Landtag wir hatten zwischenzeitlich
Umfragen die haben sie wieder bei zwei
drei Prozent gewesen dann geht es wieder
nach unten und dann gibt's immer wieder
gesellschaftlicher Ereignisse die dazu
führen dass dieses Potential dann auch
aktiviert wird das Spannende ist
eigentlich gerade in der Gegenwart dass
die AFD Wähler gar nicht zu den zu den
Verlierern so sehr gehören also wenn ich
wenn ich mir so Durchschnittseinkommen
und solche Sachen anguckt ist das bei
den AFD Wählern jedenfalls nicht
signifikant niedriger im Gegenteil
bestimmte Klientel hat sogar ein relativ
gutes Einkommen und ich habe das Gefühl
oder dass die das wenn man noch eine
zweite Umfrage daneben liegt der Befund
klar wird nämlich die Frage wie bewerten
sie eigentlich die Zukunft Aussicht also
die Gegenwart ist irgendwie besser
geworden auch in Ostdeutschland Löhne
nach oben gegangen Arbeitslosigkeit nach
unten etc aber wie bewerten Sie die
Zukunft aus sichten und da sind wir
gerade in der Situation wo sehr viele
Menschen in Ostdeutschland die auch
vielleicht am Ende ihrer beruflichen
Biografie stehen kurz vor der Rente oder
gerade auch in die Rente gegangen die
auch zahlenmäßig eine starke Kohorte
sind dass die auf einmal jetzt die Sorge
haben dass das was sie sich mit mit viel
Schweiß erarbeitet haben jetzt wieder
gefährdet sein könnte durch zum Beispiel
Diskussionen wie gerade auch beim
heizungsgesetz oder auch durch andere
Vorschläge die so aus Berlin kommen sie
sagen moment mal geht's jetzt wieder
nach unten und sie haben es ja einmal
erlebt wie es ist wenn es nach unten
geht also wie sich es wirklich anfühlt
wenn in einer Region wie in meiner weil
die Arbeitslosigkeit 26 28 %, was das
bedeutet haben alle noch irgendwo tief
in sich drin als Gefühl vorhanden und
davor wird sich natürlich eine Angst
stärker ausbilden in der Regionen die
tatsächlich nicht so viel Speck angelegt
hat wohl auch die Vermögen viel viel
geringer sind und wo man weniger lang
auch eine Dürre Periode eine
wirtschaftliche durchstehen kann das
führt er natürlich schneller zu Ängsten
und damit auch zu sehr negativen Zukunft
Erwartungen bzw Frustration das würde
aber auch die These stützen das jetzt
die Wahl in der in dragoniestnitz oder
in Sonneberg dass das ihr protestwahlen
waren wo man gar nicht über die
Kommunalpolitik abgestimmt hat sondern
in der bundespolitische Themen weil sie
haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch das
heizungsgesetz genannt das spielt auch
eine Rolle und ich glaube man die also
wir wir
Mitbewerber haben es auch der AFD zu
leicht gemacht also in die AFD hat er
sehr sehr stark auf plakatiert in
Sonneberg insbesondere die
bundespolitischen Themen und wenn darauf
dann die Reaktion lediglich ist also ihr
seid Nazis und deshalb dürft ihr nicht
dürfte nicht gewählt werden und wir
hatten uns alle unter dann ähm dann ist
das zu wenig ich würde mir wünschen dass
es in solchen Kommunismus vielleicht
auch eine Lehre aus diesen aus diesen
Wahlen dass wir viel intensiver über
diese Themen der Wahl noch diskutieren
Wettbewerber auch wahrnehmen und
annehmen die AFD auf dem man sich
inhaltlich einlässt und dann sagt ja was
ist denn jetzt bitteschön euer Plan für
Sonneberg wie soll es denn jetzt hier in
diesem Landkreis besser gehen oder oder
in Raguhn Jeßnitz meiner Erfahrung aus
den Kommunalwahlen in Ostdeutschland
Bürgermeister und Landratswahlen der
vergangenen Jahre ist dass die Debatte
auch im Wahlkampf verarmt ist ich habe
viele Wahlen erlebt in Dingen gab es gar
kein richtiges öffentliches Forum mehr
zu dem eingeladen wurde die
Zeitungslandschaft ist auch ausgedünnt
es gibt gar nicht mehr die Medien die
sowas veranstalten also Leute die in den
Vereinen oder sowas sind die sich das
auf dem offenen Tisch ziehen und sagen
wir laden jetzt mal alle ein und dann
diskutieren wir hier mal in einem
breitenforum über die
Zukunftsvorstellung für diesen diesen
Ort das fehlt die Wahlkämpfe sind auch
verarmt und damit macht man es natürlich
schreihilfen vielleicht leichter über
die inhaltlichen Themen wollen wir und
müssen wir reden das werden wir gleich
auch machen aber Herr Wälzer an der
Stelle die Frage was ist das denn wenn
die wenn den Sonneberg die AFD Themen
plakatiert die mit Kommunalpolitik nicht
zu tun haben also alles Themen die auf
der bundespolitischen Ebene entschieden
werden was ist das denn dann ist das ein
legitime Form von Wahlkampf oder ist das
Populismus das ist das ist eine
Strategie die darauf setzt dass es diese
Themen sind die einen gewissen Teil der
Menschen schon umtreiben also das ist
das machen ja nicht nur populistische
Parteien das macht ihre Partei auch das
macht an bestimmten Stellen auch die SPD
und die FDP macht es auch und jetzt
kommen wir eher zu einem zu einem sehr
wichtigen Punkt sie haben ja vorhin
schon angedeutet dass die inhaltlichen
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen den
etablierten Parteien sich eigentlich
sehr wenig an wirklich großen
inhaltlichen Themen festmachen sondern
beispielsweise wie beim heizungsgesetz
eine eigentlich entschuldigung wenn ich
das mal so sagen darf ein Pipi Fax ja
ähm können wir ja gleich noch auch
darüber sprechen aber an also mich hat
das Ganze wirklich insofern sehr
irritiert weil die Art und Weise wie man
versucht eine Klimaschutzpolitik runter
sprechen auf die Alltagsebene ist
vergleichbar damals wie man
Katalysatoren bei Pkws eingeführt hat so
man macht eine sehr einfache Geschichte
ich trivialisiere es jetzt ein bisschen
man sagt wir wollen das nicht jetzt
verändern aber an der Stelle wo es
Neukauf gibt muss es bestimmte Sachen
geben das ist das banalste was man
überhaupt machen kann dann kommt eine
Kampagne an der ihre Partei genauso
beteiligt gewesen ist wie die
Regierungspartei FDP wie die
Bild-Zeitung und alle möglichen und
plötzlich hat man so etwas wo man dann
denkt hier ist die Republik in Aufruhr
in Wirklichkeit haben ja
Umfrageergebnisse auch gehabt das trotz
des Campings 56% der der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger gesagt haben ich habe mit so
einem Gesetz gar kein Problem ja warum
denn auch wenn man das austauscht so was
ich aber damit sagen will ist dass man
aus so einer das habe ich eben Pipi Fax
genannt ach so einer gar nicht wie soll
man sagen ideologisch und sonst was fest
Machbaren
Gesetzesinitiative ein unglaublichen
Türkei macht wo die Leute dann sagen was
haben die denn was machen die denn und
warum ist eine Regierungspartei treibt
toxische Politik gegen die eigene
Regierung und was hat die Opposition
eigentlich beizutragen dafür dass das
anders sein sollte das heißt wir sind in
so einem Politikstil weil es alles Mitte
ist wo im Grunde genommen das meiste was
die Leute mitkriegen die Negation ist
das ist schlecht was die machen das ist
schlecht was die machen das ist schlecht
was die anderen machen so und es gibt
aber kein gestalten das Bild wo man sagt
man die wollen aber das Land nach vorne
bringen der Feuer wird man darauf auch
ausführlich antworten soll wird trotzdem
noch mal gerne bei dem Begriff Pipi Fax
bleiben ich kann mir vorstellen wenn ich
mir jetzt diese Sendung angucke und
tatsächlich ein altes Haus habe und
damit konfrontiert bin eine Heizung
möglicherweise austauschen zu müssen und
dann mir die Kosten vorstelle die da
kann man ja überstreichen ob es jetzt
eher 10.000 sind oder eher 25000 sind
aber es ist viel Geld kann man das
einfach so mit Pipi Fax nicht gesagt
dass der Einzelfall ist aber dass der
Vorgang als solches dass wenn man
tatsächlich Klimaschutzpolitik macht das
nicht irgendwo sich in den oberen
Wirtschaftswunderland
der Kanzler sagt wir werden das nächste
Wirtschaftswunder haben und es fließt
mich und Honig das finde ich der Fall
sein sondern es kostet an der einen oder
anderen Stelle etwas was übrigens ein
schwerer Fehler politischer
Kommunikation auch bei den Grünen
gewesen ist immer zu sagen das ist alles
dufte und es gibt vier Millionen was
weiß ich was neue Arbeitsplätze wegen xy
und so das das nicht Transformation
immer etwas kostet auch Veränderung
bedeutet das hat man falsch kommuniziert
aber Pipifax ist es deswegen weil man
jede Form einer solchen konsequenten und
notwendigen Politik in irgendeiner Weise
tatsächlich mal an einer Stelle umsetzen
muss ja wir haben früher unheimlich viel
von Zielen gesprochen Ziele interessiert
kein Mensch ja was 2015 ist ist
sozusagen betrifft das eigene Leben
nicht wenn plötzlich realisiert diese
Ziele kann man nur erreichen wir wollen
heute beginnt sie umzusetzen dann hat es
folgen und diese Folgen das meinte ich
mit dem Katalysator vergleiche meinting
auch mit dem Sicherheitsgurt oder sowas
sind im Grunde genommen ja nicht
weltbewegend insbesondere dann wenn es
ein abfederungskonzept gibt und die
Leute unterstützt werden bei diesen
Sachen immer nur für den Fall dass der
Ersatz stattfinden muss das muss man ja
dazu sagen und jetzt sie wir sind
nämlich jetzt bei der Frage der
Verantwortung der CDU da hat ja auch
Herr Kretschmer sich heute zu Wort
gemeldet und hatte danach gefragt
inwiefern da man nicht auch insgesamt
bei der Rhetorik zwischen Regierung und
Opposition etwas verändern muss was ist
sozusagen der Anteil der CDU daran dass
die politische Kommunikation auf einen
einen ein ständiges negieren wie Herr
Wälzer das gesagt hat hinausläuft und
die Leute vielleicht gar nicht mehr das
Gefühl haben da will irgendjemand noch
gestaltet
also dass man der Kommunikation zwischen
Regierung und Opposition
schon immer ein etwas ermüdendes Ritual
vorgeworfen hat ist nicht ganz neu
sondern gibt es seit Jahrzehnten und
dann gibt es eine Haushaltsdebatte und
der Bundeskanzler bringt ein Haushalt
ein und die Opposition ist dagegen und
so weiter er wütend die andere Frage ich
sehe auch nicht dass die Kommunikation
wie sie die CDU betrieben hat sich
unterscheidet von der Opposition anderer
koalitionsfraktion bei anderen Vorhaben
in der Vergangenheit natürlich ist er
auch immer Zuspitzung mit dabei das muss
auch dabei sein was ich mir persönlich
selbstkritisch durchaus einräume für die
Union ist dass die Alternativvorschläge
zu wenig kommuniziert worden sind die
die Union auch hat über die aber zu
wenig geredet wurde und es wurde sehr
viel negativ gesprochen ich möchte mich
verwehren gegen Pippi Fax weil eine
Familie die beispielsweise ein
Rentnerehepaar wobei der 1200 € haben
und die trotzdem ein Haus haben die sind
deshalb nicht besonders
die die wissen einfach nicht wie sie es
bezahlen sollen und deshalb ist das auch
nicht nur ein Sicherheitsgurten es ist
eine Katalysator Fall es geht hier ja
nicht und Teil der Kampagne war zu
suggerieren dass die Leute ihre Heizung
rausreißen müssen das war ja schon Teil
der Kampagne in dem Sinne nenne ich das
toxisch so darüber zu kommunizieren ja
und wenn darüber nachgedacht wird das
bis zu 70 Prozent die Kosten ich meine
deswegen kann ich auch mit dem Pipi Fax
das meinte ich nicht in Bezug auf
diejenigen konkret betroffen sind ich
meine das sind Bezug auf Gesetzgebung
und wenn da eine solche Form von Debatte
sich daran festmacht an etwas was eine
Konsens gibt es da was passieren muss
dann ist das sozusagen ein klein was
politisch für die Kultur nicht gut ist
aber trotzdem führt das natürlich dazu
wenn solche Zahlen im Raum stehen und
unklar ist wie es bezahlt werden soll
das dann diejenigen die davon betroffen
sind schlaflose Nächte hatten das habe
ich häufiger gehört dass Leute gerade in
Ostdeutschland
gesagt haben Sie rufen mich an und sagen
was ist denn da jetzt los sie haben ja
schon seit mehreren Nächten nicht mehr
geschlafen deshalb wären die weiß ich
nicht wissen wie sie es wirtschaftlich
stemmen sollen das muss man doch ernst
nehmen
darüber haben wir gerade gesprochen
deswegen hatte ich ja auch noch mal
Herrn Wälzer und eine Konkretisierung
gebeten aber was man ja auch nicht ganz
von der Hand weisen kann ist dass eine
Diskussion innerhalb der CDU
aufgebrochen zu sein scheint dass man
möglicherweise auch unterschiedliche
Stilistik bei Oppositionsarbeit an den
Tag legen kann wird jetzt einfach mal
die Stichworte Herr märz und der wüst äh
einbringen wollen gibt es da
möglicherweise nicht doch
unterschiedliche denken Schulen wo man
sagt man kann und muss vielleicht
Oppositionsarbeit auch anders machen
also ich glaube Günther war es der der
gesagt hat man darf den Leuten keinen
Scheiß erzählen das würde ich immer
unterschreiben das stimmt das sehe ich
aber auch nicht dass wir den Leuten
scheiß erzählt haben es macht ja auch
gar keinen also wenn wenn heizungsgesetz
war jetzt die Sorge die die Leute hatten
geht meine Heizung kaputt
und ich darf keine Gasheizung mehr für
sechs oder 7000 Euro einbauen sondern
muss eine für 30.000 Euro nehmen wie
mache ich das dann eigentlich und
niemand weiß wann seine Heizung kaputt
geht insofern verbindet sich damit eine
durchaus reale Angst und ein reales
Risiko ich glaube aber dass dieses diese
Diskussion um dieses Gesetz dass man die
ein kleines bisschen größer auch fassen
müssen muss was
an was glaube ich auch vorhanden ist in
Ostdeutschland auch in anderen Teilen
des Landes ist ein großer Zweifel dass
die Art und Weise wie wir die klimawände
in den verschiedensten Bereichen angehen
dass das tatsächlich so funktionieren
kann und ich glaube dass gerade im Osten
das gerade im Osten in Gespür dafür
herrscht wenn hier etwas
planwirtschaftlich gedacht wird und wenn
wenig Markt im Spiel ist und dass solche
planwirtschaftlichen Überlegungen wie
wir sie gerade im Bereich wenn der
Energiewende z.B haben dass die an
vielen Stellen auf nicht funktioniert
werden und deshalb die Diskussion
durchzuführen das hätte ich mir von der
Union mehr gewünscht wie man mit
marktwirtschaftlichen Instrumenten die
Energiewende besser bestreiten kann ist
glaube ich sinnvoller als sich da auf
die g-boote und Verbote zu konzentrieren
die er jetzt im Vordergrund stehen und
da gibt es vielleicht im Osten noch eine
größere Sensibilität wissen Sie was das
Problem ist so wie sie jetzt
argumentieren sind sie das Problem weil
wir reden eigentlich darüber was die
mentalen und motivationalen Ursachen
dafür sind das ist politikvertrauen
absinkt das vielleicht am Ende sogar das
System Vertrauen absinkt die Leipziger
Studie die sie vorhin selber erwähnt
haben gibt da ja sozusagen wenig anders
zu Optimismus das ist ja schon relativ
dramatisch aber sie nutzen jetzt diese
Situation um noch mal die Position
gegenüber dem heizungsgesetz darzulegen
das heizungsgesetz das war doch nicht
meine meine Intervention ein Beispiel
dafür genommen wie eine Distanz entsteht
wie die Menschen die dann am Ende
Kreuzchen machen
irgendwo die politische Kultur
wahrnehmen so und das war mein Punkt in
der Art und Weise wie der Kampagne
gemacht wird jenseits von wirklich
begründeten Inhalten ist etwas was
Politik Distanz erhöht es erhöht es
einfach und wenn sie so argumentieren
dieses eben gemacht haben dann denkt man
aha jetzt macht der noch mal die Nummer
um das heizungsgesetz und wiederholt die
Argumente aber das ist ein Problem sie
sind in den etablierten Parteien
sozusagen sehr weit entfernt von dem was
die Leute umtreibt und sie sind es nicht
nur auf der Ebene der Sprache sondern
sind es auch auf der Ebene der Inhalte
und das liegt daran dass man einen Punkt
den ich vorhin machen wollte dass sie
sozusagen alle Parteien der Mitte sind
und im Grunde genommen gar keine
erkennbaren Differenzen haben und
deshalb die Differenzen austragen müssen
an daher kann man einen Begriff an eher
Pipifax Gesicht die Theorie die dahinter
steht ist ja dass man sich in der oder
die Unterschrift die man setzen könnte
ist dass die Union sich darüber Gedanken
machen wird wie man halt eine
Oppositionsarbeit kenntlich macht gehen
Vorschläge
er arbeitet ich will einen Punkt in den
letzten Minuten aufnehmen er rede mal
ich weiß dass sie auch da ja dran sind
wir haben schon den Begriff der
Brandmauer im ersten Drittel der Sendung
genutzt jetzt ähm hat man ja einfach die
Wahlergebnisse im Osten wie man sie hat
dann muss man sich auseinandersetzen die
Frage ist komplette Abgrenzung zu einer
erfolgreichen AFD im Osten kann man das
Aufrechterhalten wackelt diese brandmaul
oder bleibt sie stehen
aus meiner Sicht wird der
brandmauerbegriff politisch ein Stück
weit auch missbraucht nämlich immer dann
wenn er inhaltlich aufgeladen wird immer
dann wenn schon der Union den Verstoß
gegen brandmauerregeln vorgeworfen wird
wenn sie irgendwie über mit Migration
spricht oder wenn sie über Energiewende
Fragen sprich ich habe das kürzlich
gehört bei Frau Neubauer die sagte auch
bestimmte klimapolitische Position
gehört denn aus ihrer Sicht hinter eine
Brandmauer sowas ist glaube ich
schädlich weil damit die demokratische
politische Debatte verengt und verarmt
wird wir müssen die Themenfelder
miteinander diskutieren auch kritisch
diskutieren und da hatten Union normal
beim Thema Migration auch eine deutlich
andere Position als es die Grünen haben
und das ist auch mein aus meiner Sicht
auch legitim Brandmauer so wie ich sie
verstehe ist die ist die ist das klare
versprechen und die Sicherheit die auch
nicht im Zweifel gezogen wird dass ein
Demokrat niemals einen Extremisten
vermacht verhilft
und natürlich stehen uns alle Demokraten
in Deutschland stehende Union näher als
alle extrem als als jeder Extremist das
ist doch völlig klar ja und wir dürfen
aber nicht den Begriff überstrapazieren
wenn es jetzt zum Beispiel in Sonneberg
ein Landrat gibt von der AFD der
natürlich mit seiner Kreisverwaltung ein
Haushalt aufzustellen hat was soll denn
dann bitteschön der Kreistag dort machen
der guckt sich dieses Haus diesen
Haushalts Entwurf an und er wird
Maßgaben machen und er wird diesen
Haushalt so verändern damit er im
Kreistag auch eine Mehrheit findet das
ist das was dann Auseinandersetzung und
politisches Alltagsgeschäft sein wird
alles andere würde ja dann in dem
konkreten Fall bedeuten dass der
Landkreis 8 Jahre lang nicht regiert
wird kein Haushalt hat und den Bach
runter geht das kann ja kaum ähm im
Sinne eines Demokraten sein die AFD ist
einfach Verdachtsfall zumindest in
weiten Teilen für den Verweis
Verfassungsschutz wir haben aber die
Situation im Osten ist sie für viele
Menschen wählen ist sie wählbar es ist
das Ergebnis einer demokratische Wahl
was man so anerkennen muss verbietet
sich trotzdem jeglicher Art der
Zusammenarbeit aus ihrer Sicht naja wenn
wir die die Fälle international angucken
und jetzt eigentlich im Moment nicht
sehen was würde innerhalb relativ kurzer
Frist diese AFD wieder von der
Bildfläche verschwinden lassen Klammer
auf möglicherweise wäre die die
Halbierung ihrer Wahlergebnisse
tatsächlich dadurch möglich dass Sarah
Wagenknecht eine Partei gegründet ist
sehr spannend weil es ein Potenzial ist
nach einem was man weiß was
gewissermaßen auch Leute die jetzt ihr
Kreuz sind bei der AFD machen würden
darüber ziehen würde das ist glaube ich
für die etablierten Parteien auch ein
Problem
im Nebensatz lassen Sie uns diese
Theorie doch mal einen Herrn Redmann
Weitergeben der sich ja sehr gut
auskennt in Brandenburg ist sein sein
Landesverband wo er herkommt halten Sie
das für realistisch dass eine
Wagenknecht Partei im Osten
das Potenzial hätte das Wahlergebnis der
AFD zu halbieren also das was eigentlich
für mich mehr als versprochen hatte also
halbieren weiß ich nicht aber auf jeden
Fall gehe ich davon aus dass eine
Wagenknecht Partei aus dem Stand bei den
ostdeutschen Landtagswahlen die fünf
Prozent Hürde überspringen würde wir
erleben auch in Ostdeutschland eine
Linkspartei die gespalten ist in einem
lagen Wagenknecht nach naslager unten
ein eher sagen wir mal großstädtisch
geprägtes modernes linkes Lager und da
bedurfte sicherlich nicht viel Aufwand
da auch Unterstützer zu gewinnen also
acht bis zehn Prozent sind da mindestens
in den in den ostdeutschen Ländern drin
und die würden dann zum Teil von der
Linkspartei kommen zum Teil vielleicht
sogar zum größeren Teil von der AFD wo
die Person Sarah Wagenknecht bei den
Anhängern eine ziemlich hohe Sympathie
genießt das ist die Theorie die sie dann
beide haben wir werden das beobachten
können wie das ausgeht ich hätte sie
aber unterbrochen sie waren gerade dabei
erweiter zu sagen ob sich die jegliche
Art der zusammenarbeitet
eben sozusagen mit der Faktizität von
Wahlergebnissen
mittelfristig überhaupt nicht sie haben
es ja eben wunderbar beschrieben auf der
Ebene dessen was er an Landrat tut also
man kann sozusagen für die für die
praktische Arbeit ja keine Brandmauer
errichten und wenn wir Entwicklungen
anschauen die wir sehen Österreich mit
der FPÖ gehabt haben oder wie wir sie in
Italien sehen oder in vielen
europäischen Ländern jetzt sehen wo ist
die paradoxen Konstellationen gibt oder
geben wird das eigentlich eher linke
oder links liberale Parteien dann
plötzlich Koalition eingehen mit ultra
rechten ansonsten merkwürdige
Konstellationen entstehen denn wird man
glaube ich realistisch sagen müssen so
etwas wie die Aufrechterhaltung einer
totalen nicht Kooperation ist ein
unrealistische Perspektive das wird
einfach so sein und Sie haben ja vorhin
errät man das fand ich auch richtig
gesagt das ist eine Aufgabe ist für die
etablierten Parteien diese Partei eben
nicht mehr als Protestpartei sondern als
Mitbewerber zu betrachten man mag das ja
gar nicht sagen die haben ja Konsens
hier in diesem Tisch dass das keine dass
das Antidemokraten sind und dass die
eher die Vorhaben diese diese Form von
Gesellschaft eher zu zerstören als etwas
dafür zu tun trotzdem stellt sich für
sie ja die Aufgabe wie können wir
eigentlich unsere Verantwortung für die
Demokratie unsere Verantwortung für das
Gemeinwesen so deutlich machen
artikulieren dass die die der
allergrößte Teil der WählerInnen Wähler
sagt das ist für mich okay das was die
machen das nicht okay also er wird man
wäre eine Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD
einen Schritt in Richtung europäischer
Normalität oder kann es so eine
Normalität in Deutschland aufgrund der
besonderen Geschichte schlicht nicht
geben
wir müssen natürlich sehen dass gerade
jetzt in Ostdeutschland die AFD eine
ganz besonders rechtsradikale
Vereinigung ist und sie ist ja nicht
ohne Grund auch beobachtungsobjektes
Verfassungsschutzes zumindest in Teilen
insgesamt verdachtsobjekt was im
Brandenburger Landesverband angeht und
ich kann mir für die CDU nicht
vorstellen dass wir mit mit einem
Verfassungsfeind Koordinaten oder ihm
zur machtverhelfen das ist das
widerspricht allem was uns lieb und
teuer ist auch nicht andersherum es gibt
ja zum Beispiel in Deutschland die
Erfahrung dass man mit einer Partei die
auch mal eher am Rand wenn auch der
andere stand dass man da so Duldungen
bildungskonstellationen gemacht hat er
wundern es war nicht die die amanz sind
gewählt aber man hat sich halt so macht
verhelfen lassen
auch das kommt für mich heute nicht in
Frage das liegt auch daran dass die
Umfragen das auch gar nicht hergeben
dass wir gerade machen das schwarze
Katze spielen ja und wie schlimm kannst
denn noch werden damit redet man so ein
Erfolg auch weiter herbei also ich bin
der bin da nicht dafür die Umfragen im
Brandenburg geben sogar gegenwärtig
wieder die madfinder zweier Koalition
zwischen SPD und CDU her und das ist das
worauf mich konzentriere im nächsten
Jahr ich will keine Minderheitsregierung
im Brandenburg sondern wir werden eine
stabile Regierung im nächsten Jahr auch
hinbekommen wenn wir uns als Demokraten
clever verhalten wenn wir die Debatte
führen zwischen den demokratischen
Parteien und gleichzeitig auch die AFD
argumentativ widerlegen also das Ziel
AFD zu halbieren steht das noch ich habe
dieses Ziel nie formuliert das war ist
ein 5 Jahre alter Aussage glaube ich von
von Friedrich Merz ich würde gerne die
AFD halbieren aber ich heiße nicht für
sehr realistisch dass das irgendwie in
kurzer Frist hinzubekommen das liegt
auch daran dass man ja von allen
Untersuchungen weiß dass bei den AFD
Wählern der Anteil derer die sich
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können
irgendeine andere Partei zu wählen mit
Abstand am höchsten ist und wenn es
zumindest noch nicht ganz von der Platte
ist das Ziel wie sinnvoll ist es die
Grünen als Hauptgegner auszumachen auch
da glaube ich lohnt das gesamte Zitat
Friedrich Merz hat gesagt die Grünen
sind der Hauptgegner in der
Bundesregierung mit nichten hat er da
irgendwie was in Bezug auf AFD
relativieren wollen das ist glaube ich
einen manchmal auch absichtliches
Missverständnis was da vorgenommen
worden
also kann man ihn glaube ich auch nicht
fahren
glaube ich schon falsch verstehen wollen
wenn man das so
jetzt richtig gestellt werden die
Gelegenheit dazu ich würde als
Schlussfrage
gerne noch mal einen Blick in die
berühmte Glaskugel werfen wir haben im
nächsten Jahr haben wir ähm
Wahlen in ostdeutschen Bundesländern
auch in ihrem Heimatland in Brandenburg
wie wahrscheinlich ist das aus ihrer
Sicht dass da die AFD die stärkste
Partei wird
sie ist gegenwärtig gleich auf mit SPD
und CDU in den in den Umfragen in
einigen Umfragen auch vorn das kann
durchaus passieren aber selbst wenn es
passieren würde wäre es kein Beinbruch
also wir sollten jetzt nicht darauf
gucken wie das Kaninchen auf die
Schlange das am Ende ist etwas was
glaube ich der AFD noch am meisten hilft
wenn da so eine erwartungsspirale in
Gang gesetzt wird dann in Brandenburg
wird jemand Ministerpräsident wenn er
50% der Stimmen des Landtages hinter
sich vereinen kann und davon ist die AFD
meilenweit entfernt das würde auch im
nächsten Jahr nicht passiert aber für
alle drei aus deutschen Bundesländern
den gewählt wird aus deutschen
Bundesländern wird die AFD die nächsten
auch kein Ministerpräsidenten in
Ostdeutschland stellen und diese diese
diese diese Debatte darum zu führen ist
wieder etwas was am Ende nur noch
Polarisierung hilft wir sollten
miteinander darüber diskutieren welche
Politik in den nächsten fünf Jahren in
den ostdeutschen Bundesländern gemacht
wird kein weinbruch das Schlusswort bei
dem keinen ballbruch habe ich eben
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen gezuckt denn
sozusagen der der Sachverhalt dass die
Parteien schon gleich aufliegen und je
nachdem selbst auf der Ebene der Bundes
der Bundesrepublik im ganzen die AFD
schon inzwischen vor der SPD liegt würde
ich das als ein sehr großen beeinbruch
und ich würde das als eine Aufforderung
an Sie und die anderen etablierten
Parteien echt mal wirklich verstehen zu
gucken wie kommt diese Stimmungslage
zustande und die kommt zustande weil die
Distanz zwischen der Art und Weise wie
sie Inhalte formatieren und wie wenig
sie haben vorhin auch von Zukunft
gesprochen
zukunftsgestaltungsoptionen bei ihnen
allen deutlich werden das ist das was
die Leute umtreibt und das ist ihre
Aufgabe sich darum zu kümmern ich bin
mir sicher die Parteien unter anderem
die von Herrn wird sich damit
auseinandersetzen ihnen herzlichen Dank
fürs Kommen für die Diskussion und Ihnen
zu Hause herzlichen Dank für Ihr
Interesse bei Phoenix folgt jetzt wie
immer das aktuellste zum Tag
bleiben Sie jetzt bei uns und bleiben
Sie gesund tschüss
[Musik]